[Music]
a
[Applause]
[Music]
Vanessa you're born and Brad as a 7-Day
Adventist where's your personal
challenge
today well
today it's just sometimes overwhelming
seeing that people in your church are
not awake to the
issues that's happening today like the
current events and how that's leading up
to Jesus coming back you know things
like like the climate change agenda
that's one
thing I don't realize that that's
something that they're using to bring
the Sunday law in so that's one one
thing you know looks like you are an
active Watcher of WhatsApp Prof looks
like you have watched quite a number of
episodes how did that change your
life I so appreciate appreciate Walter's
mannerisms and the fact that he doesn't
have to shout at you to get your his
point across he's very educated and one
of the things I also appreciated is
talking about um things like um
evolutionism versus creationism he
actually has um examples and points he
can bring out the science behind things
which is is just exciting and it helps
you if you want to tell anybody else you
know what I mean
but he's just so knowledgeable on more
than one aspect and also the Bible and
and it's great to watch the
program when you watch WhatsApp Prof is
there something in between you say oh I
must share that with others and how do
you do
that ah very interesting you know like I
said one of the things creationism
that's one way and even in church I
found even in church because when
children are going to public school or
people visiting a lot of times they
don't even believe in in the creation
story so that's one thing I've been
trying to bring out and use some of the
points that he's had um been able to
show share with us on his program and
use that to kind of rebut some of their
arguments because they really are into
what the world has told them so coming
from the Caribbean what is your personal
goal to reach out yourself and help
others to understand the gospel of
Christ well you know different cultures
have different ways of being reached so
um it would be good to also go back home
to some extent or even if I don't
physically go but um also people in our
Islands as well but people here from
different cultures I think it's easier
for me to move between cultures because
I I um have sort of a link so there are
a lot of um diaspora in this country as
well so you know we have a link just
because we have a shared background
history type of deal so it's easier for
me to speak to people maybe in the
dialect that type of thing sometimes
people will kind of gravitate to you oh
are you from you know and it's easier to
open a conversation with other people
that way as well so yeah now when you're
here in the booth of clash of Minds
looking around first time that you
probably saw Walter life I
guess right so what is your your
impression about the work Clash of Minds
really is
doing um I think you guys are doing such
a wonderful job you're reaching people
all across the world and using the
internet and media in such a wonderful
way um and yes there are some ways that
people can be reached that may be um in
person sometimes it's hard and it's also
good that you know if I can't say
something in such an eloquent eloquent
manner I'll be able to um Point somebody
to the videos so that's that's a good
way as well sometimes I can share
that um especially when we talking about
things to do with um with current events
he puts it in such a way it's hard for
me to say it and you know sometimes
you'll try to say something to a person
and they just tell you oh please that
can never happen you know for example US
Constitution there is no church in state
and and he'll explain things in a better
way that I than I can so I think it's
okay to sort of do a secondary
evangelism where you use someone else's
words that that are able to explain
something a little better than maybe you
can if you're not as eloquent as they
are thank you so much for taking the
time to answer a few question may God
bless you and same to you and the entire
Ministry and the people that I see on TV
and that I don't I God bless all of you
thank you for coming all this way across
the ocean to come and visit us here in
Orlando
[Music]
oh
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
[Applause]
Claire yes it is such a pleasure meeting
you and hearing part of your story I
think it's very unique would you like to
share with me where you actually coming
from and give me some background
information on your personal life and
since you're here with your husband you
just open up your story to me thank you
um
where I came from as for today you mean
I came from Canada but I'm originally
Lebanese from
Lebanon and uh I was born and raised as
Catholic in a a Jesuit Bordan School in
Lebanon and then so all I knew all my
life up until I left Lebanon it was that
there's only Catholics in the world we
were that Shel Ed
in um but when I came to Canada after
the during the war um I realized that
there is a lot other denominations than
just Catholics so as I was what I was
taught in in the boarding school is that
Genesis is just a story that Abraham
told how would he know how the world
started
and
Revelation uh I was told that it was
John was left alone on an island and he
just lost his mind and so he went up he
came up with all these
stories
so it stuck in my mind like what are we
here for then if the beginning and the
end are not true where are we what's the
sense of being on on this Earth
something must have happened for you on
a personal basis to decide I need to go
to
Israel and then you went and what
happened so I have been searching all
these years um and then I went to Israel
in
2019 I went there for a month and so two
weeks in I went to the Jordan River and
I see I looked around and I see these
people happy and they're getting
baptized and they're praising and
they're praying and I said Lord why
aren't you showing yourself to me I have
been looking for you and you are not
showing yourself to me but you know what
I'm not giving
up I will not give up unless you bless
me and then all of the sudden all that
noise you've been to a tourist area and
you'll you'll hear the noise everywhere
all that noise just quieted down I could
not hear anybody
anymore the only thing I heard is a
voice saying to me cleanse yourself from
your past belief
system and I am aquaphobic you know what
aquaphobic I I I'm too scared of going
down to the water that I don't know
what's in it and the Jordan River was
very muddy
but somehow I ended up in in the uh
River and I prayed and I said Lord
whatever belief system I had in the past
I'm just letting go of it right here in
this water and I'm going up so I did and
as soon as I came out of the water I
felt so much
lighter when I went back to the hotel I
called my husband because he was still
in the
Canada and uh he says oh I had to pause
a video very interesting video when you
called and I said which fil he said
somebody called Walter VI and he's
saying something about the Sabbath and I
said well Mark we'll talk about it when
I get home so when I got home I said so
what is it about what's this Walter VI
saying who is he he says did you ever
hear of a nomination called Seventh Day
Advent I said no I have no idea he says
well that's what Walter V is he's a
Seventh Day Advent
pastor and the video that I was watching
it had it's it's
about uh observing the
Sabbath and when as soon as he said that
I just sat on the chair and I started
crying my eyes out and he says what are
you crying I said you know I was brought
up in a culture where the week days were
numbers and we only had names of two
days in the week so the first day second
day third day so on and then Friday is
called the Juma which is the prep day
and the Sabbath called
Sabbath and I said to my husband I said
I I couldn't believe I was brought up
with these names of the days and I
didn't even pay attention to
it and then we sat and watched uh Walter
VI the one that my husband was watching
by himself and I was blown
away the it's it's like I had I had a
scale on my eyes and it just wiped away
it I I could see I could see the truth
and I could understand what Walter was
saying and uh and then the pandemic
happened to us in my home it was a
blessing because then we didn't have to
go anywhere we just sat there and
watched Walter one video after the other
one video after the and some of them we
would watch two and three times because
we were trying to follow with the
Bible and what an amazing thing that was
I always to to Walter that I am here
today that's that's for
sure when you look at a situation that
both your husband and yourself were
during the same time on search more or
less finding both there is no
coincidence what is God's plan for you
personally what have you learned through
that experience for yourself and your
family you know I often thought I am the
one that prayed at the Jordan River why
did God show my husband first because my
husband is an
analyzer and he does not if he's not
convinced he will he will not move along
and that was going to be an obstacle for
me in my home right so he was convinced
before I
was so we can both be on the same path
and what's from here
on we've been called we've been called
but I don't know for what I don't know
but um it's a it's we we've been so
honored to be part of God's plan if we
weren't I don't think this would happen
it didn't happen by accident that all
the way I am in in Israel and my husband
is can in Canada and while I'm praying
he's watching
Walter that that's that's a miracle by
itself God works with Miracles what's
your personal Vision on the war Clash of
mind is doing and why do you feel that
that Ministry is called to do a
particular work at the end of time you
know the the way how Walter understands
the situations the way how he did his
research
in the
background he taught me not to just take
things of forace value I
mean Walter ma did so much research that
in such a deep deep
uh in in in a very deep place that he
brought it up to the surface nobody else
I've never heard of anybody else doing
or saying what he did or say and you
know it's um what's what's beautiful
about it is that he was on the other
side he was on the other side and now
he's on this side and he knows both
world and he showed us both world he
told us the difference between Both
Worlds and if it wasn't for for Clash of
Mind through the pandemic I I don't
know see we were so brand new we would
have been lost so easy because of all
the confusion that was happening but
then when we sit and watch uh uh Clash
of mind and when we sit and watch what's
up Prof we were looking forward to it
every week so we would we would kind of
get a hint of where we're at and what is
going on and what to look for I've never
um there was a series I wish I could
remember which series that was um where
I sat down with a pen and paper and took
all the explanation like what does the
water mean in the
Bible what does what does uh um the
stars mean in the bible I I never heard
of of anything like that so I sat and
wrote them all down and that helped me
immensely to study the Bible on my own
because where we are my husband and I we
have nobody to teach us we have nobody
absolutely nobody to teach us so we're
we count on on Walter
VI videos to to understand the Bible the
way we need to to understand
it thank you very much for sharing your
vision your past and history and your
present of course with the team of clash
of Minds we wish you all the best and
God's Mighty blessings thank you and
thank you so much for your services I
pray for your group every single day
that God will keep you and will save you
because we need people like you at this
time in the in the time of History
that's for
sure thank you so much amen yeah
[Music]
hi I'm sitting here with uh Faith LEL
and you represent an organization called
streams of light International right yes
sir and you have this great controversy
that you publish but it's a great
controversy with a
difference if you page through it you
will find on at various chapters you
will find a QR
code and if
you uh scan that then you will get all
the information regarding this chapter
plus videos and everything tell us about
your project well we want to see one
book in every home in North America by
2026 and so what we have is a book that
we believe can get into every home is um
in a way that may overcome obstacles
that some people might have they don't
like to read oh well this book will read
itself to you and if they are not
interested in a history book Bible
prophecy we have a Health magazine that
pairs with it that can meet the needs
that they may have right yes and um yeah
we have uh put together this Outreach
packet and a program for helping local
churches to be able to distribute in an
organized way with Maps Outreach maps of
the area know where to go and what areas
they've covered and how how to uh knock
on the door in in a Winsome way engage
people about this book and pray with
them and offer Bible studies and we're
getting to partner with churches all
across North America and we're excited
that in 2025 we're going to be taking
this uh Mission International going to
Europe and and other places in the world
as God opens up the doors so we're very
grateful I think this is a wonderful
idea because you have the book so for
those who like to read they can read the
whole book it's unabridged yes it's
complete those that do not like to read
and want to know about these things they
click on the QR code they get all the
information in video form so it's it's
all here in one little booking it's a
brilliant idea I think so so if people
want to support this and uh receive
these books and I I gather you're giving
them away at Cost we are certainly
trying in North America in 2024 we have
a special deal for churches that partner
with us I don't know what it'll look
like in 2025 but we're trying to keep it
as reasonable as possible because we
want this book to go out so if you want
to be part of this Evangelistic Outreach
you can contact Faith at streams ofl
light.net all right I'll repeat that
Faith at streams of light
.n net and get a whole bunch of these
books hand them out like the leaves of
autumn amen and hit two birds with one
stone we don't want to kill those birds
right no we want to keep them alive but
uh for those who are media junkies
there's a QR code for those who like to
read a book great everything in one
package praise the Lord anything else
you want to say no I think that's it
thank you so much it's a pleasure God
bless you thank you and you have the
right name Faith so let's take it
forward in faith let's pray heavenly
father I think this is such a wonderful
idea and I pray that you will bless this
project and bless the distribution of of
this wonderful book The Great
controversy that it may go out like the
leaves of Autumn and bless Faith as she
works for this Mission and tries to Pro
remote this in jesus' name amen amen
[Music]
hi I'm sitting here with Michelle hi
Walter and I'm so happy to be sitting on
this
furniture right it it it matches
perfectly the Lord had it ready for you
several years ago when we got it so tell
us how this furniture got to be in our
set here at ASI well we actually bought
a town home a rental town home so it's
our
Airbnb and it was beautiful colors right
the the console the couches uh you know
we just we thought it was a pretty color
but they decorated all of the town homes
with all this stuff and we've had it for
about 3 years um the last over the last
week L reached out to my friend Lan my
good friend um Lan who she knew because
Lon orderers stuff from clash of mind so
they had a friendship there and um and
came to pass that Lana was asking
questions and we said well we we have an
Airbnb they could stay at we will be
glad to help you get ready for this
setup because of what a blessing um
total Onslaught your ministry has been
for us and our family so we said we
would be glad to help so hence when they
were in there they said okay well forget
the other stuff we offered can we have
this stuff it matches perfectly and of
course we said yes most certainly well
that's very kind of you thank you for
yes helping us to put this together
because you know when you travel a long
long way it's hard to Source everything
that you
need but what I'm so surprised is how
everything fits in with the color scheme
and everything it's like God planned it
a long long time ago he did and me and
Henry and Lana shop the carpet down to
the carpet was yes it looks beautiful in
here what a blessing thank you now how
how did you get to be associated it with
Lana and with Clash of Minds team Clash
of Minds well I have been a 7day
Adventist for about 21 years now I was
baptized in the Sunday a Baptist Church
Calvary non- denominational so I was
there for about 5 years I was studying
Revelation and I read all the Left
Behind series I read all the Tim Le I
was like Lord wow this is so exciting um
I had a dramatic conversion because I
was a mess before I gave life to the
Lord so about 5 years I was studying
Revelation and Daniel and I just I was
like Lord I'm never going to understand
this stuff right just doesn't make any
sense I won't ever get this then I got a
flyer in the mail which was had pictures
of that you know the Beast and all that
and said Revelation seminar didn't say
what church was putting it on so I went
to that so that was about 21 years ago
the best six weeks of my life I sat
through I saw Genesis to Revelation
opened up before my eyes that's when I
became a 7-Day Adventist right so I said
okay I am a 7-Day Adventist I'm going to
keep the Sabbath now I understand it was
I was so happy so that's how I became an
Adventist but on my journey of 7th Day
Adventist I when I first became I was
always in fun fun churches you know we
always had nice good fun music we always
you know did what we want it was a very
relaxed a very relaxed atmosphere right
so that was pretty much forever in all
of the churches I had to the Adventist
churches but to me it was comfortable I
taught Sabbath School I taught
Pathfinders I whatever I could do to
teach to be a part of I was a part of it
and I was excited to do it but I met Lon
and Dwayne in
2018 my good friends who were a part of
helping this as well and so I learned a
little bit then and I would hear people
say oh you should eat you know you
should be eating healthier or that music
is bad for you my response was always
the Bible says you can eat clean Foods
you know like we don't eat pork or
seafood but the Bible says you can eat
clean Foods right we stick it to health
principles we F exactly that's what it
always was and then the music they made
no sense to me I'm like what's wrong
with our fun music like we're going to
the fun churches right this is this is
what we're used to my kids love it I had
young kids at the time so we continued
on that journey and didn't feel very
fulfilling but I I was like Lord
wherever you have me I'm going to do
your do do your will right and do what
you want me to do and So
eventually um they would L and Dwayne
and we started a revelation seminar at
the house and for my kids to do a series
and they finally got to the stage where
they were like here listen to this we
want you're you're ready for this right
listen to this it was the total
Onslaught Series right so I was like
okay well this looks cool you know let's
I'll listen to this and I had been
listening to Doug Bachelor and going to
all every reading every book could about
you know Adventist for 20 years great
but I was still dressing how I want to
wearing makeup eating how I want to like
again my heart was right I love the Lord
with my whole heart but never once did
anybody tell me I needed to do anything
else with conviction I didn't hear about
the spirit of Prophecy I didn't hear
about any of that they never said
anything about the spirit of Prophecy
not that I recall certainly not
specifically in any case they didn't
make it prominent they didn't make it
prominent never mention any of that
stuff and I don't they didn't I don't
think they ever never really talked
about it honestly but so I watched the
total Onslaught and when I started it I
probably finished that whole series in
about 6 weeks if that I watched at least
two a day I was maybe more but I was
like and when I watched it the scales
just kept falling off my eyes and at
that point I told L and Dwayne I said am
I missing something here I said I've
read the great controversy I've read The
Desire of Ages the Great all the five
you know I read all those more than once
at times I said but what are they
talking about this Spirit of Prophecy
why do I feel like there's something
missing that there re something is gone
like what am I missing right so they
said um they said oh the testimonies of
the church have you read you know the
read the testimonies of the church I
said what are the testimonies of the
church and the early writings councils
on diets and food I I nobody had ever
brought these to my attention before so
the first thing I did was ordered the
nine volume series and I started reading
it and Walter I if I would tell you the
first I didn't get through the first few
chapters and I almost felt as ashamed as
I did when I first repented and came to
the Lord because I was like oh Lord I
have to change well you know I have to
change I am just like the world our
churches are just like the world just
like what is out there and God wants a
peculiar people he is coming back soon
and he wants people to be the spirit of
Prophecy he wants to take us back to
what it was like originally yes yes and
the only way he can do that is to do it
incrementally step by step stages
because we are so far gone so far so far
that we cannot even
comprehend the distance that is between
the original and our fallen State now I
mean Walter I was I went from fast food
one to two maybe three times a day a
year and a half ago this was all recent
you know a year and a half ago to trying
to figure out how to cook vegetarian I
don't even know how to cook unhealthy I
wasn't raised in a cooking environment
and learning how to cook so all this
year it's been a journey but an amazing
journey like I I'm and the Lord has
allowed me to he's got given me this
beautiful Farm to where I can bless many
people a a huge a huge area where I'm
starting Revelation seminars and
Ministries but it's a journey but it's
it's a wakeup call for us that this
testimonies of the church this nine
volume series they got to start with
total Onslaught then they got to get the
testimonies and their early writings
because man my life this past year and a
half is just a dramatic change and
amazing the Lord that says narrow is the
path yes and few there are that find it
yes yes now that used to bother me yeah
because why should it be so
hidden but then there's another verse in
the Bible which says seek and you shall
find so the condition for finding is
seeking and I meet so many people in the
world that
say I ask the
Lord where is the answer I don't know
what to do please reveal yourself to me
I did that myself I remember sitting in
that little chapel and there was just no
answer from God and I said I'm done with
this there's just no
answer and I
said if you
exist reveal yourself to
me in other words you were seeking right
yeah yeah and I never expected to find
what I found
but I did you did so until you get to
that point when you say Lord show me
show me yes you're not he's not going to
force himself upon you yeah so you have
to get to the point to ask the
question and he creates circumstances in
your
life so that you become willing to ask
the questions yeah and the devil put so
much stuff in your way so that you don't
get to answer the or ask the question
and you don't seek and if you don't seek
you don't find and that is the way our
world and our and our church when I see
the churches you know I I want to I want
to yell I want to because they're I want
to get up in their condition and there's
no need to see there's no and there's no
need to change I mean after I learned
all of this I started watching me Med on
the brain of course I started studying
all this stuff about music about the
drops about all the stuff in the Church
of course about the the diet the dress
code you know the no makeup it's the
most humbling experience but you know
what I said Lord it's less of me I don't
want people looking at me this is not
about me this is about him and I want to
shine for him but it's only those who
are really searching and seeking and
it's a shame because there not a whole
lot how much knowledge do you think does
God have comp to us whole lot unlimited
right so how much should we
seek a whole lot as much yes as much as
we can get it's it's keep going until he
God is waiting for our people to get
ready you know to get there's never a
time when we can say we have arrived
because we will be searching and finding
for all
eternity but time is short as you say as
we all know when we're studying these
signs of the time we don't have we're
not time setting obviously but when you
look at everything that's going around
you I just it is like after all this
stuff that's gone the year and a half
I'm like come on people let's do this
start reading I'm going to post the
volume you know series The N volume
testimonies for the church the I'm
through five volume Five I'm like
halfway through volume Five I started
about a year ago right all the early
writing so you know but I'm almost there
you know but five is very nice yeah
volume nine is also very exciting
because that comes right at the end and
there are many things in there that
should Inspire us definitely but you you
know the Lord's sense of humor because
when I was going through all of this and
we have the town home and I have the
ministry that I started I have a big
tent on the property to start Revelation
seminars I told the Lord you know what
maybe Walter VI could come here one day
and do a series over there or maybe of
course I mentioned a few other people
too so this all to me is just I told you
the Lord has a sense of humor he is
amazing you're you're close enough just
to be a part of this to be a blessing to
support this because we have a work to
do well all I can say is may God bless
you as you try to share that there is
more than warming up church pews there
certainly is yep there is a whole world
out there that the Lord wants to expose
us to there's a the Health message as
you have discovered yeah and and people
in the in the churches think that it is
a
restriction it's not a restriction it's
an explosion it's for our benefits yes
to get us healthier yes yes I realize
that if you can get people to understand
that wavelength wouldn't it be wonderful
it would be and my wavelength used to be
yeah I'm sure God wants us to eat
healthy that would probably be nice he's
probably like okay it would be nice if
you would eat healthy now I discovered
no God tells us to eat healthy it's not
him asking us FL lightly it's him I mean
of course he has mercy and Grace believe
me more more mercy and Grace but he's
like no this is this is what I'm telling
you to do study I'm waiting for a people
that's really going to listen to me and
uh I
believe that the time is
coming when the distinction between
those that follow the health message and
those that don't will become very very
prevalent in the world yes and the
sooner we do it the
better but those of us who have moved
along that line we've started a health
Ministry now called
Verity and the object is to help those
who have not yet discovered the benefit
yes but unfortunately many of those that
Discover it will disc cover it because
they've fallen so far behind and have
become so ill that they cannot operate
anymore wouldn't it be nice to skip that
and jump on the bandwagon before we get
to that stage unfortunately for at least
my me and my family we haven't had the
health ra bad Health ramifications where
you know we've gotten on getting it and
it's a it's a process believe me we
aren't fully there yet it's a process a
progressive it's been within the recent
year but most certainly it's such a
blessing it's such a blessing to see how
the Lord blesses you and honors you when
you are trying your best to to honor him
as best as you know how and I'm telling
you seek as you say Seek with your whole
heart and you will find and he will open
up doors he will bless he will bless so
the health arm opens up the Mind Y and
when the mind is open the spiritual
aspect
and well issues can come in we have to
have a clear mind during what's coming
Upon Us in the world as well soon we'll
have to be able to discern between truth
and error amen because the Devil is a
master at selling error he is he
definitely is he had me sold like he had
me sold for many years so do you have
any last encouragement or word that you
want to give to listeners you know I
just want to say if you haven't watched
total Onslaught it's a 36 you know
series I watched it on YouTube watch it
because it will change your life and the
scales will come off you will see it the
testimonies for the church volume one
through nine early writings read them
and study them because God is doing a
work in these these last days and those
changed my life like you cannot even
imagine you can ask my friends so most
certainly get in there the spirit of
Prophecy God says you know it's not just
it's we have to be studying the spirit
of Prophecy if we're going to going to
be how ready for the Lord to come back
thank you Michal so we have a prayer
together sure heavenly father thank you
for the testimony of Michelle she was in
the church for a long time and then she
discovered that the Lord has a special
message for his people at this time in
Earth's history and I pray that you will
use her mightily Empower her and make
her a Bas in this time a beacon of light
that people can radiate towards and I
pray this in Jesus name amen amen
[Music]
well we have a interesting guest here
Ivan Raj very nice to meet you nice to
meet you too thank you for having me
thank you for coming will you mind
briefly to just tell us a little bit of
your history and uh there's some
interesting things that you were in know
a lot about um yoga and sure sure
actually um so I was born and raised in
India I studied in a Hindu school for
some years and then we became Adventist
and that being said uh there was a point
in my life where I had uh I had a
question about which is the True
Religion which is the truth and uh one
of my employees introduced me to a
Muslim apologist who was actually
misquoting from scriptures I did not
know he was misquoting from scriptures I
was leaning towards Islam and
questioning
Bible at that time one of uh my
Adventist friends introduced me to the
Islamic connection to
Rome by Professor Walter that lecture on
the Islamic yes yes of the total
Onslaught series total Onslaught Series
so I watched that one lecture and then I
had a conversation with my boss
and then I took a 2 and 1 half weeks
break and I watched all of total
Onslaught at least two or three times
back to back to back binge watch right
so that actually transformed my life and
then I came back to my job I said I want
to quit my job and I said I'm going to
start a Ministry and I'm going to live
the rest of my life for god wow that's a
nut show that's amazing so when was this
so This was um around 13 years ago okay
yeah and then are you in currently
involved in Ministry yes so we have uh
my business Ministry partner Heidi
Tomkinson and I we actually started uh
Heidi self kitchen where we make your
favorite carab Truffles and we started
that 10 years ago when we started we had
a outline of our business because our
business was focused Ministry focused so
we actually had a print out and we met
uh Professor Walter at one of the g at
the GCS in 2015 we started in 2014 in
2015 we came up to him and we gave him a
print out of our Business outline he
went through it I don't think you
remember it he went through it and he
came back next day and he said you're on
the right track he said oh wonderful so
you still with Heidi's Kitchen yes yes
Heidi Tomkins and I we are still
business Ministry Partners last year we
also started in addition to Heidi self
kitchen we started the wisdom Pearl and
then 5 years ago we started producing
videos on yoga and yoga called yoga
unboxed where uh I explain
the roots of yoga found in Genesis
chapter 3 tell us
about okay so in Hinduism they Hinduism
teaches so Hinduism has two broad
branches one is um atheistic the other
one is
theistic and uh the the the the theism
the theistic branch of Hinduism they are
involved in idolatry the the atheistic
part of Hinduism they are involved in
nature worship
pantheism so yoga fits in the atheistic
part of Hinduism and the word yoga means
uh to link the human mind with shiva's
mind so that being that being said uh so
Hinduism teaches that the first uh
actually one particular Hindu Guru
actually promotes this teaching that the
first uh student of yoga was a woman and
Shiva is called as the AI Guru meaning
the first Guru and he sat under a
tree and the tree is called tree of
knowledge and he taught to the woman so
yoga has two basic the foundation is two
um the human is divine you will be like
gods and goddesses that is the teaching
of the serpant yes and Shiva is the God
of destruction is a God of destruction
and when we look into the attributes of
Lucifer and Shiva it perfectly matches
one the side one the same so different
names same person same teaching it's
interesting that we accelerate that they
bu has as its logo
or God of destruction yes yes yes so
when when I when the Lord put me in
front of all these truths when the Lord
brought me into all this information I
actually did not want to talk talk about
it but I felt very bad because a lot of
people are being deceived so there's an
archaeological evidence found in India
where uh 5,000 years ago archaeological
evidence shows Shiva depicted with horns
so he's also called as a hor D he's
androgynous he also has bne
feet like buff yeah same same uh baffet
the same um personality or entity and uh
so since 5,000 years ago uh ancient uh
people who lived there were called as
Harens it's called harapan civilization
uh they he was a prominent deity for the
harapan according to archaeological
evidences and the seal that is found in
the haran civilization which is actually
the Northwest part of India it goes all
the way up to Iran it was the largest
ancient civilization all over the
civilization especially in the Northwest
part of India the harapan I'm sorry the
the pashupati seal it's called pasupati
which means lot of the beasts seal is
found in the
excavations so that's a little bit about
um
yoga and are you in your program
training people or educating people with
regard to the dangers and La yes yes
there's physical mental and spiritual
dangers first physical uh uh so yoga has
eight limbs they call one of the limbs
is this posture one of the limbs is the
meditation emptying the Mind Right In
other words shutting the frontal lobe
from thinking so the physical aspect of
yoga posture the human body is not
designed to bend in in those directions
you know um so a lot of Christians in
the west think it's just exercise excise
but even Islam has exercise in their
worship Islam has nine stretches in each
of their namas they have to do nine
stretch nine postures and so physical
expression of worship is part and parcel
of other many other religions it's so
that's a that's something which is new
to the Western Christian mind so it
affects the body that's why a lot of
yoga teachers also have hip replacement
surgeries because a body is not designed
to bend like that then then when we get
into the U mental aspect of before that
uh meditation right so meditation a lot
of people experience peace of mind but
it's actually not the peace that Jesus
gives because when the frontal lobe is
forced to shut like forced to
concentrate or focus on one thing so
melatonin is sent out to the body
thinking that oh this guyy is sleeping
right now because the brain is not
working so that is artificial
stimulation of melatonin that is why in
Hinduism it's called a state of bliss
that is what is packaged and sold as
peace but the peace that Jesus gives
gives us courage it helps us to face
problems in life head on so basically
what the difference is the one shuts
everything down yeah and that's
basically also the state of nirvana in
Buddhism yeah everything is shut down
yeah but Jesus says he's coming to fill
you yeah so it is the antithesis mhm in
actual fact when you take it as far as
it can go in Buddhism when you reach the
state of Nar you reach the state of
nothingless so isn't it the worship of
Oblivion of non-existence is whereas
Jesus Christ comes to offer you life and
life to the full yes and it's always
been amazing to me how you can create a
religion where nothingness non existence
basically the celebration of Death
Becomes your religion yes that's true
and how do you feel now that you moved
from there into adventism what is your
what is your passion in order to reach
people that are trapped in what you were
involved in yeah so I see this is
deception and there's actually one of a
prominent politician in South India he
actually called Hinduism as a
religion that represents onion I'm not
trying to offend anybody we have some I
have some very good Hindu friends but
that's what he said because as you keep
on peeling on and layers there's nothing
inside so that is how it is so so the
concept of love does not exist in
Hinduism or Buddhism because it's all
about
Detachment yeah whereas in Bible B
Christianity is attachment and um
speaking of Buddhism Buddha actually
after
meditation uh meditating for long
periods of time every day uh he actually
died of um um a gut issues because as
obviously there a brain and gut
connection so when so the gut becomes
weaker as a brain is suppressed from
thinking artificial the two work
together together yeah so the the aspect
of diet and mental health is very much
associated with yeah now when you came
into adventism was this a shock for you
or was it a relief when you discovered
all of these things oh it has definitely
reliev the truth Set Me Free and uh I
say that with all my heart um
because two things I understood as I was
researching on yoga one is the the level
of deception is just amazing because the
deception is happening right in front of
our eyes and the world doesn't even know
that yeah so it made me realize the the
level of deception the craftiness of the
enemy and how he has Enslaved the
world with
craftiness that is one next is if the
enemy can be so tactful and so um subtle
uh then who is then having the final
Authority with love and how much more
big he he is how much more Grand he is
in his character so I was able to
discern and differentiate between the
enemy and the Lord and Savior Jesus
Christ it is so since then I just you
know recommitted my life to do God's um
God's work I'm still a work in progress
of course but God is using well may God
bless you in your
ministry and I pray that you will reach
many many people with the truth as you
say the devil hides his lie in plain
and that's part of his Mastery manages
to deceive people true not only in the
religious world but also in the
political world yeah so we have to be
very
circumspect and use the Bible as our
basis yes and I'm very glad very
grateful that the Lord used total on yes
bring you out of that world into his
beautiful life thank you so much much
for all you guys do at Clash of Minds
thank you so much for having me as well
well just before we wrap up they were
you guys are having something at in
September yeah yeah yeah so um so in mid
September September 13 14th we are
actually organizing our fourth Outreach
conference through our organization the
wisdom Pearl and uh if you viewers can
watch the previous videos and talks on
our YouTube channel the wisdom Pearl so
we are organ ing a conference at the ark
encounter Museum uh in Kentucky okay so
we have a lot of non-adventist audience
as well in the in the in our conferences
that are attending and um the goal is to
connect um the Advent message with the
out you know with the non-adventist
community and the non-adventist
audiences yes that's it the arc
encounter ways that it's Kentucky yeah
it's in Kentucky and we have actually um
the founder of the Ark encounter and the
Creation Museum he's going to be
speaking on the evidence of the great
flood and he's also we' also requested
if he can be interviewed by uh our
Pastor Ron Kelly on stage excellent
thank you can we have a prayer together
yes Absolut thank
you Heavenly Father we've spoken about
very important
Ventures exposing issues that affect
millions of people's of lives and I pray
that you will use
our friend mightily in exposing what is
happening in the world out there and
bringing them into the wonderful light
of the ministry of Jesus Christ in Jesus
name we pray amen amen
[Applause]
[Music]
hi Rachel hello it's great having you
here at the booth of clash of Minds
thank you it's good to be here just give
me a little bit of a of a background on
your story yes
um just just a brief um I grew up in the
Adventist Church um and I was I was just
here telling Walter that um
I spent some time you know out of the
church
and um for quite quite a number of years
and then about 7 years ago God has
brought me back in and it's just been
amazing what God has brought me through
um when you fill yourself with program
internet whatever you come across
WhatsApp Prof I believe how how has
WhatsApp Prof influenced and strengthen
your own life just give me some
information where you said well it was
very impressive I learned something of
it and I want to share that and how did
it change your
life yeah that's a great question um
I've watched the whats up profs ever
since they
started and um just amazing information
and
um I find they
always I'm not just convict of things
but but remind how close we are to to
the Lord's second coming you know and
and the preparation we need to have for
that and um and certainly I've I've
shared um several of those with family
um you know during the pandemic there
were some of those that that I really
felt like needed to be shared
um about some of the health
um the health issues that were involved
there but also um how it relates to the
times we are living in and Shar those
those with family members
yes I don't know the background of your
family children partner whatever but is
it is it important for you to share the
gospel
in the area you're living because your
you yourself believe it's so strong and
you you see The Nearness as you just
described of Christ what can we all do
to press together in your personal
opinion to make people understanding
listen it's just going to be a few short
years or less for Christ to return there
is some kind of an urgency to it right
yes yes I think we do need to keep
telling whether it is family or friends
or or even others maybe those we work
with or that that that don't even know
right but but to but to continue to tell
them that Jesus is coming and and the
specific reasons why that um that the
ministry here at Clash of Minds has has
presented so so well you know what
what's going on in the political realm
or in other places in the world right
that and I do think when people start to
see that that that they'll wake
up what a beautiful statement thank you
so much for sharing the time may God
bless you thank you God bless you as
well
[Music]